here in germany angela merkel's
conservative cdu party is once again
taking the lead in opinion polls
ahead of september's general election
and that's bad news for the green party
just four weeks ago the greens had
overtaken the cdu but
since then they've been losing ground
leaving many wondering
if they'll run out of steam
during last sunday's regional election
in the state of saxony unhealth the
greens
suffered a setback was there pool
showing a sign that they were losing
momentum ahead of september's general
election
in a recent poll the conservative cdu
retook the lead with
28 the sbd is polling at 14
the far-right afd and the
business-friendly fdp
at 12 the left party at 7.
the greens are polling at 20
germany's election campaign is not in
full swing yet
so many people have other things on
their minds like the pandemic and the
vaccination campaign
47 percent have already received their
first dose
i was vaccinated last week i feel really
relieved
i think we all feel the same way life is
slowly returning to normal again
some of my friends have gotten the jab
already and it's a great relief my
parents also got vaccinated it took a
load of my mind
um i think vaccination is being going
much better as well it was a pretty bad
start i think earlier in the year but
now
i think it's going great um so yeah now
i think
generally good direction here 71 of
germans say they have been treated
fairly regarding the vaccination process
53 percent welcome the end of priority
groups
while only 43 percent think children age
12 and up should be vaccinated quickly
almost two and three germans say the
current covet 19 measures are
appropriate
more and more of the restrictions are
now being lifted as infection rates
decline
and dwe's chief political editor
michaela kufner is standing by at the
green party conference
in berlin michaela we'll get to the
greens in just a moment but first
i want to look at that what we just
heard in the report overall people seem
to be satisfied with the vaccination
rollout across germany
despite let's face it a pretty terrible
start and the country's struggle
throughout the pandemic
absolutely i mean right at the beginning
during that first wave it really was a
success story because germany acted
really fast and prevented a lot but it
was very very slow
to pick up when it came to vaccinations
and i think that polling
that we're just seeing coming in is an
expression of the collective sigh of
relief that you are feeling here in
germany
that most restrictions are being dropped
one by one you can sit in a cafe
outside again you can go into a shop
even some shops without getting tested
and that's happening across the country
so it's a taste of normalcy
and that's clearly what people
appreciate what about political support
you're at the party conference as we
just mentioned of the green party who've
lost
support and the confidence of voters it
might say it sort of seems
how how can that be explained
well that was a couple of blunders were
to blame there on the green side if
you'd asked me a couple of weeks ago it
was the greens rising and rising and
some poles then
passed angela merkel's conservative cdu
csu block because they had a lot of
infighting
now there was were some minor i'd say
small scandals
about undeclared christmas bonuses
and also analina berbach the top
candidate who will be
elected here on saturday being caught
out not being precise enough when it
comes to her cv those seem to be
very much beginners mistakes but it of
course raises question
is this party is this woman fit
to become chancellor and that's what the
party is grappling with at this very
moment in time
as they sit down at their first kind of
physical meeting
with um just under 200 people here in
the room and it's just a few months out
from those national elections
in september what are the green party
going to do to try and win back the
trust
well they need to demonstrate unity and
that is the home weight they need to do
over the next 48 hours and that has not
been their forte in the past
so it will be a very interesting test
how serious the party is the leadership
is and how serious all delegates are
about um demonstrating that they can act
together
despite quite a few contentious debates
expected on
co2 a pricing fuel pricing here in
germany
also potentially even a more speedy
exit from fossil fuels here in germany
but in that everybody hopes will be more
of a footnote
and everybody hopes that they can
demonstrate that much much needed unity
to help analina baerbot climb those
poles once again
alright thank you dw's chief political
editor michaela kufner reporting from
the party conference of the greens
you